east is done
valentino's day's done i'm gonna lift in
the morning a little jiu jitsu at lunch
all i give a [__] about two bears in the
cave
slinging dick don't expect what do you
think i'm gonna light myself on fire
podcast is brought to you by on it go to
honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 18th of april the joint
is brought to you by zip recruiter
it's a great idea to keep learning
skills
listen over the pandemic i learned how
to play the ukulele a little bit if
you're always learning it keeps you
sharp like zip recruiter the a1 is
always learning if you're hiring the a1
gets better and faster at finding the
right candidates for all the roles you
have and right now you can try
ziprecruiter.com joey for free
free zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates
up with your job you then review
candidates and invite your choices to
apply
for your job that's why zip recruiter is
the number one rated hiring site in the
us based on g2 ratings and now you can
try ziprecruiter for free that's gratis
at this exclusive new web address
ziprecruited.com
joey j-o-e-y that's
joey jrey
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
oh [__] and it's 4 20 this week
[__] so of course i'm talking
about the best pipe [__] anywhere the
freeze pipe you get an ice cold hit
every time it's like blowing a dead dude
this is how it works
the pipe comes with detachable chamber
that's in the freezer beforehand when
you're ready to see the devil
the hot smoke pat you go to the freezer
first you take the chamber you put it on
the [__] pipe you fill that
[__] up with some laughing gas and
when you hit that pipe
the hot smoke passes through the frozen
part cooling down the smoke as you
inhale it's like inhaling a nice warm
[__] fart your smoke will be so cold
you think you're [__] frosty the
snowman listen to me
i love [__] the freeze pipe
whether it's the bubbler the pipe or the
[__] bong it's non-toxic and it
freezes faster than water and stays
frozen longer freeze pipe cools down the
smoke
by hundreds of degrees
joint listen
joint listeners go to the
freezepipe.com again to freezepipe.com
and press encode
joey j-o-e-y
and save 10
on your first order whether it's the
bung the pipe the bubbler
that's the
t-h-e
t-h-e freeze pipe dot com
pressing code joey j-o-e-y and save 10
if you could smoke from it
freeze pipe makes it [__] let's
get this party started it's monday we're
smoking from coast to coast monday to
sunday
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what up you bad [__] uncle joey
here welcome to uncle joey's joint on a
beautiful monday the 18th
of april east is done
valentino's day is done [__]
passover's done
it's all done we've covered the [__]
spectrum
and now straight to [__] memorial day
slinging dick and by the [__]
pool that's all i'm looking right now
all i give a [__] about
is my local pool opening i got six weeks
i'm counting it [__] down you
remember when you were a kid you had the
calendar on the wall with the x's and
[__] 38 days till school's over
that's how papa is thinking about the
[__] pool this year i got a system
i'm gonna lift in the morning a little
jiu jitsu at lunch
right to the [__] gym one o'clock
smoke a couple numbers
get some vitamin d kill the covert
and move [__] forward that's it man
everybody wants to know what's going on
so i'll [__] tell you
how it evolved and how it took place i
know
uh two bears in the cave was up last
week
and the [__] thought they set me
up and whatever the [__] they were
thinking i love those two cousins you
know you got to love burton time i i've
i have a lot of respect for both of
those [__] guys as comics
as parents as human beings
i mean they've done things i've never
even dreamed of doing they're younger
than i am
tom segura
has really come a long way but one thing
he always stayed a [__] great guy you
know tom's
a great guy when tom kept calling me to
go down there i was like you know what i
don't know
and i went down there and listened if
you don't think i had i was like that
chubby girl
at 2 30 in the hotel lobby i knew what
was going to happen you know what i'm
saying like you know what's going to
happen you'll end up going to some guy's
room sucking his dick i know i'm the
chubby girl i get no love you know what
i'm saying so
you know sometimes you know what's gonna
go down why are you
resisting it i didn't
i knew at some point i was gonna do
something on this stage the energy was
gonna call me out there
and it was very weird because it all
can't listen man i told you
[__] once i told you a thousand
times
i love
how things go down
there was a thing somebody told me years
ago that if something sucks in the
beginning
a movie
you're recording an album with your band
you get there and the [__] guy is
under the couch on heroin
it's gonna be a long [__] six weeks
you know
uh you're building a house the first day
you know it's just you you guys know
unless you're a [__] idiot
you know you ever do something with
somebody and you know in the back of
your mind it's this is a [__] no-win
situation
and they're like let's go let's dig six
more inches and you're like we're just
wasting our time somebody's gonna hit a
[__] line and get [__]
electrocuted and you know i'm saying
like it's just it just doesn't pay like
i believe in [__]
never giving up
but i also believe sometimes it's a very
fine line between giving up and throwing
your cards in
you know last week i was talking about
my friend sarah rest in peace who
died last week i was telling you guys
the story kind of saw them and what i
was hinting at was
even when i was on the church you know i
go on every day and i preach
don't give up
but whoa whoa whoa there's a [__]
fine line
between you spinning your [__] wheels
and you pushing to get ahead there's
always been that fine line you know when
you have to catch yourself
because if not you you're killing
yourself to live in the immortal words
of black sabbath that's what you're
basically that that's how i always
it always came back to that you're
killing your [__] self to live so
you got to know when to
you know do 85 and went to put the
[__] brakes on i went to go you know
what i gave this my all
you know what i'm gonna do i'm not gonna
stay in l.a i'm gonna downsize this i'm
gonna take my comedy act to phoenix
get a day job with insurance get my life
together do some writing and stick to a
plan it all comes back to what i guys
tell you about a [__]
about a [__] plan you always have to
have a plan
for the last
i think three weeks before
a little liquid iv always good for you
on a [__] monday morning
a little concord grape tremendous
three weeks before i i went up to tom's
i wanted to take a look before i threw
in the towel
i wanted just to go to a comedy show and
take a look take a look to see
if i remember something just take a look
but i knew if i took a look
i'm one of those [__]
if i put a uniform on i got to go to war
like i'm not one of those guys that
could sit from the [__] sidelines so
you guys don't remember telling i told
you [__] i went over the stacks
one of my favorite breakfast joints they
do comedy i like the owners the two
women
but i couldn't get parking
that was
maybe the night before
tom yes it was the night before time i
went to stax just to check out stand-up
just to see if it was something
that i even wanted to be around or
whatever
i'm not bored i don't need a [__] job
i need a hobby
i'm pretty busy with the [__] girls
i'm pretty busy here nine out of 10
times when you talk to me after three in
the afternoon i already got my night
planned out you know this last week
thursday we went to the [__] movies
to see i don't know some
[__] bunny rabbit that spins around
or whatever
i don't [__] know gizmo sonic the
hedgehog or whatever the [__] you know
20 people there
like kids and adults you know i didn't
plan what do you think i said i think i
want to see hedgehog no
they call me i go that's it it's that
simple you got a family you got i don't
know
friday night
we went to a [__] tremendously like
family restaurant because this [__]
13 14 of us every [__] friday last
night i think there was like 16 of us
and we or friday night it was like 16 of
us and we had to find the place to eat
the kids have no [__] sports you know
what am i gonna tell them i can't
i can't go out to dinner because i gotta
go do a [__] spot at some hell oh
[__] you
saturday i went to an easter thing they
they made ribs the kids [__] ran
around and jumped up and down you know
so i i don't if i i knew that i have to
do it during the week
the weekends are [__] to put for me
you know so it's basically a hobby so
when i went down to
toms you know i
when i got off stage my mind was racing
about all the things that i that were
possible to me
and then over the next three days when i
came down from the adrenaline
i thought about all the things that i
didn't want to do
you know so it was a perfect balance for
me i was there
he took me by storm
i didn't sleep a night you know i lost a
night's sleep just thinking about my
next move
and then uh
i still didn't know after i got on stage
rich foss we were talking he goes
vinnie's open dino's got wednesday night
opening let's go let's get this [__] the
[__] over with
you know and what [__] got me mad was
listen i tell you guys the truth don't
don't expect nothing
don't expect what do you anything i'm
gonna light myself on fire
i mean i'd love to tell you that for the
last 18 months
i wrote religiously i didn't
i wrote you know for the book i wrote
the story in my life i outlined [__]
like that every once in a while if i
cracked a joke i wrote it down like you
know
new jersey has the highest rate of
autism you know [__] like that you know
just to remember it if i ever did want
to put a bit together but guys it was my
first time on stage well
come on people like wanna i gotta get a
ticket it's really potless and first of
all guys if i'm doing jersey let's get
this [__] straight just so you know
because you know i don't like telling
people this but because i think that you
figure it the [__] out if a show is sold
out
and it's anywhere in jersey new york
philadelphia
don't call me and hit me up for tickets
and i'll tell you why it's not that i
don't want to give you tickets
did you forget i'm from here
so whenever i have a show i'm already
dealing with hey can i get tickets from
the kids i grew up with
my nieces my nephews
yeah what do you think this is if i was
in california yeah i got nobody if i go
to phoenix
and you're like joey i'm in town can i
get two tickets i'll give you eight
tickets
because i got nobody in phoenix or
dallas or [__] miami you know what
i'm saying put your [__] brain cap on
but if i'm injured like some guy's like
any possibility of any tickets i go guy
come on just come to that you're not
missing nothing
you're not missing nothing
you're not missing nothing it was
nothing listen guys one thing we have to
take away from ourselves
it's an immature thing it's very
immature
and i'm gonna flip this around for you
right now in a way that you can't
i don't know i i think that we're living
in a life that you don't want to miss
anything
and i gotta tell you something it's
healthy for you to miss something
when i was 18 19 you know when you can't
talk a [__] out of missing
anything you ever been 18 or 19.
remember when you had it in your head
i'm going to see penguins whatever and
your friends like you but the show's at
midnight i'm going to see penguin
because you didn't give a [__]
and you went and went home you were like
what was that all about
i mean guys i've been to maybe four
[__] shows that i left there and went
wow everything else is good it's
memorable
but nothing for me to [__] kill
myself over like that was great you know
nothing like that at all i mean you know
so i i want you guys to start thinking
about like
man i really want to go to that show but
i can't you know what [__] him
[__] him let joey come see me
start doing that when i was 18 i used to
force myself to stay in on friday nights
because i never thought that i could
survive like in the back of your mind
you're like i gotta go you know why
like do you think you're never gonna
[__] survive the next day so i
remember like going to bed sober and
waking up and like looking out the
window looking at my phone like what did
i miss
you didn't miss anything
the best line i ever heard was in the
rat pack
when dean martin looks at joey bishop or
whatever he goes you know what the best
thing is
one of these days all these [__]
idiots are gonna wake up
with a hangover and go what the [__] was
it all about
you know we go through patches in our
life like we
we go to bands for a couple years or not
we go to like comedy shows then we go to
a bar for that bar yeah i'm not at
remember there was always that one old
jerk off like me uncle louie that sat
there like he told all the girls give me
something for the cheek and you know
that [__] idiot and you know he
always tried to hit you with alcoholism
wisdom and [__] like that
and you're like man i can't picture my
life without that bar well now you're
married you got kids
do you even think of that [__] dump
anymore
do you even think of those old alkies
that are probably still there
uh reciting the same [__] they're
reciting when you were there 10 12
[__] years ago
and you go yeah that was a festive time
in my life at the same time you're like
i couldn't live without it
guys it's the same thing i'm just a fat
[__]
that cracks a joke every once in a while
nothing that's going to nothing that's
going to put money in your bank
nothing that's going to change your life
you're not going to go home and go wow
you know wow you know guys i never went
home and went wow
what what movie is it that
the guy like yells you're not gonna
believe what happened again the old man
is like what are you talking about the
guy said you're not gonna believe it he
showed up and he's like go to bed
go to [__] bed what's the matter with
you you know guys it was a 20 hour
[__] show
thank god
i wasn't greedy and i didn't like
headline myself with two unknowns
if i'm gonna get up on stage i want you
guys to have a good time too and i want
you guys to have an experience jimmy was
[__] great you know the next day
people were like jimmy faunting is great
you didn't know this i mean he's been
doing it for 25 [__] years what do
you think he's been doing [__]
playing the bass he's [__] great
jimmy he's [__] great he's a
professional and and rich vos is another
[__] killer
and i had them you know go up there we
split it three ways i don't give a [__]
i just the point of this everything
listen one of my dearest friends once
told me something that a lot of people
didn't know even myself
i'm a very calculated person i smoke a
lot of dope i might not have the best
language in the world i curse i say some
[__] up [__] but guess what everything
has a [__] plan
i
my whole plan for wednesday night was
just to get on stage
and do 20 [__] minutes
calm
and collect it
i wanted to
you know i wanted to say like i just i
didn't write any jokes i had ideas you
know
i'm sick and tired of hearing about the
[__] slap and nobody wanted to say
the truth about what the slap was you
know what the slap was about you know
why the slap happened you know what why
that's never happened before
black people they had black people a ton
of them at the [__] oscar you guys
want black lives matter that's what you
[__] get i got nothing against
african americans i love them but the
slap
is two brothers slapped each other you
never see white people doing it there i
just said what everybody else is [__]
scared of saying and i said it on
[__] stage and it's the truth that's
what happens when you invite black
people to your party now you got it you
see i'm saying you wanted [__] uh
what the [__] you wanted denzel
washington to show up
and the ghetto brothers showed up what
are you gonna do i ain't mad and neither
should you but say it don't keep beating
around the [__] bush you [__]
with i don't know what the smack was
about well you invited [__] black
people to your party that's what happens
from time to time they don't play games
you guys like to walk around hahaha i
loved your movie your movie sucked okay
i guess [__] chris is in a movie
[__] uh whatever his name is didn't
like it from 10 years ago and he just
remembered while he was sitting there it
wasn't about jade it's like chris rock
made that movie pooty tang [__] him i'm
gonna go up there and smack him now 10
years 20 years later i don't [__]
know but that's what everybody's scared
of [__] saying so let's [__] say
it that's everybody's been digging at
people think about it digging at people
what was the smack about oh my god
what'd you think it was about say it
there was a couple brothers there you
know what i'm saying
one guy put on the jackson five
the other guy wanted to hear the [__]
osmonds you know he's a [__]
scientologist and that's what happened
you know i talked about [__] the
lgbtq [__] i said everything offensive
so i could get it out of the way so
people could know that my [__] night
you went i said like eight or nine
offensive things just to
i don't give a [__] guys
i didn't have planned you know one of
the biggest things that pisses me off
one of my biggest pet peeves
that pisses me the [__] off
is when people go joey i'm i'm getting
up on stage for the first time you know
i'm gonna get up in like eight months
you know two things bother me
i'm gonna join the gym soon but i gotta
get in shape
listen to what you just said you [__]
miserable bastard
i want to join the gym but i got and get
in shape or i want to join jiu jitsu
i just got to get in great shape
do i look like i'm in shape
do i look like [__] joe rogan he
knocked me and [__] no
i go to [__] jiu jitsu i go to the
blue class i go to the core class and
i'm gonna tell you something
every class i go to i get this much
stronger
this much stronger i don't go to class
planning [__] well yeah when i go to the
blue class i plan to go and maybe try a
move or try from somebody's you know
coming into my guard i want to try a
triangle or try a burn whatever the [__]
the same thing with comedy i always have
one goal when i go on stage
to remember one joke
and guess what i never [__] remember
it
okay
you know when you write you every day
you try to write so i gotta set eight
o'clock mike i'm gonna write out my set
list
and then i go holy [__]
i wrote that joke the other night when
i'm stoned i'm gonna try it tonight that
takes me about six nights to finally get
in the rotation i go oh hold on people
this joke doesn't belong in there but i
want to try it anyway and they know
where you're at and they try but i
wasn't going to write a [__] uh
an hbo 20 minutes for a [__]
wednesday night
all i was trying to do was get my timing
mouth to audience audience back
my feet
try to get them [__] level again
because when you do comedy yeah that
idiot's just standing there for 45
minutes if he's a [__] idiot if he's
delivering if he's unleashing
my feet my [__] finger my toenails my
fungi toenails are biting into the floor
because the energy i'm propelling out
should be making me fall forward
that's what you don't understand so
there's times you do a 45 minute set you
get back to your whole term and go jesus
christ why am i so sore
because you've been biting into the
[__] energy
you've been biting into the [__]
earth for you to unleash your stuff
you're basically just a conduit
that's why i'd rather do comedy outside
when you're on the [__] ground or on
this on the grass and you have sneakers
on because basically you're just a
[__]
uh a windsock of sorts i don't mean to
say like a window what's that
it's like a tesla coil you're basically
getting energy
you're digging for energy when you when
you uh
start going to chi gong i thought you're
gonna go to chi gong
or when you got when you start going to
tai chi and all those
asian arts older people doing because
they're trying to dig energy out of them
and one of the moves that they do a lot
is to push down
and up
down and you'll see that if you if
you're driving by like and you see like
20 chinese people and ain't cooking
spare ribs and they're [__] doing all
this [__] that's what they're doing
they're putting the energy down and up
when you go to acupuncture and they hit
you with those [__] needles it opens
up the
the chakras i know joey why are you
talking about this what are you going to
do teachers downward dog next no i'm
just trying to make a point here that
your energy goes up and down in your
body
you know so when you have pain somewhere
there's a blockage the energy is going
down but it can't come back up so
there's some type of blockage you have
swelling inflammation whatever the [__]
you may have you know something in your
brain you know
last year when i started the [__]
joint
the first six months i had a blockage
going to my brain like it was going in
but it wasn't coming out it happens it
happens you're not [__] balanced and
that's why i would stand up you have to
be totally [__] balanced but i know
this going in
when you're first starting they don't
tell you this in the judy carter book
jean parade doesn't tell you and even
joey diaz and joe rogan and bill burr
good comics will forget that because
it's not relevant
but then it is it is
but we don't why would i teach you
something if you're just going to sit
there and go
what are you talking about joey i
i've been listening to pride for years
he never spoke about this i i listened
to jim gaffigan he never spoke about
this i listened to [__] you know john
mulaney he never talks about this
because we don't even know what's going
on
until you get away from it and go holy
[__] that's right i gotta start doing
some stretches from my legs or some
[__]
downward dogs or something because at
the end of a 40-minute set
you feel it especially two [__] 40
minutes like i why do you think i
wouldn't sign up for [__] like a tour
with two shows a night
can't cover the spread
that's a lot of energy moving through
your body and if you do it all of a
sudden bro you go back to your room and
just pass out the lights just go out
so i don't want to i want to get into
this a little like this week my goal is
maybe to get on stage twice
where am i going to go i have no [__]
idea
i have no [__] idea but i'll look at
the schedules around town and i'll jump
on it and my writing
yes that's another thing we have to talk
about
one of the main reasons i wanted to take
a break from stand up
yeah i wanted to find out what my next
move was
but also to change my point of view
i think that
if you listen to my cds
or see my specials i think the last two
specials no the last special and the
last two cds rolled into one another
this is just me saying this
a lot of people would never say this
this is after i got here
because sometimes before you get on
stage what i like to do is listen to an
old piece of work
and that'll bring some
you know oh my god i said that oh my god
sometimes i'll listen to a cd which i'm
already iffy on but i'll watch this is
not happening which i know they're
[__] solid i i'm very proud of this
is
not happening like four of them i'm
really happy about there's one that's
not too good i don't know which one it
is i got a room
but i have to go back sometimes and i'll
look at those
and i knew that my pov had to change
joey what's your point of view just your
point of view how your world collides
with the rest of the world that all had
to change i was talking too much about
fingers and [__] and stinky monkeys
and all it was time to move away from
that nobody told me i knew this
when i shot
um
the one special not the netflix one
but the other one
socially acceptable when i shot social
unexpect acceptable
my goal was to change my point of view
the only problem was my point of view
hadn't changed
do you know what i'm saying like i tried
to force something
that i could never change anyway
the only way you could change your point
of view is time
you know
i didn't know this
i did not know this but this is why you
took that break from stand up after you
shot your special
you usually shot a special and your
agent would have eight episodes for you
on some stupid tv show as a garbage man
or whatever
because those eight weeks is where you
change your point of view things change
for me they didn't change like that they
did
but they didn't
so i had to take the point of view i had
in la as a [__]
pothead
[Music]
uh her up type dad
to what i became now which i'm close to
retiring
you know not really i wouldn't bring
that up on [__] stage but
you know it's a different world what i'm
going through now is completely
different when i was going through five
years later
mike's life today
is different than i was five years ago
so if you were to write a song today
it wouldn't sound like the song you
would sound five years ago
you know what i'm saying you would like
five years ago you would write a song
like i'm young
and i don't give a [__] if i have herpes
you know you know all those wild eye
songs or wild lyrics
and you know maybe he doesn't want
herpes or whatever i'm just exaggerating
but you guys understand i'm talking to
you now he's got the two kids he's got a
car payment he's got a house payment
he's getting married
this song would be a little bit more
not liberal
but it'd be a little bit more uh not
family i'm not that he's gonna i've been
through the desert with a horse with no
name
but he's gonna write something not as uh
what's the word like you know [__] wild
he's not going to write a
what's the dirty guy
from kentucky
wheeler you're not going to write a
wheeler song
yeah you're married you're with a child
now can this time trying to say to you
you know like
steep and male chick
i can't believe
i said his neighbor
i cannot believe i said his name right
stipe mayo chick
is a different guy today
i love stipe [__] tough [__]
i wouldn't want to face him in an alley
and i don't want you to think
you could face steep mayo chicken and
alley
but stipe is not the same guy that he
was
they first won the championship winning
the world title
gave him a little bit more money gave
him a little bit more opportunity
he's a loyal [__] that dude he's
a bad [__] he continued to be a
volunteer fireman and whatever the [__]
he does
saving lives that's a real life superman
but what i'm saying is when you look at
stephen he's got his glasses on
you know he's got a nice tight haircut
you know he's uh he's got a smile on his
face
when you're first starting to fight
you're [__] angry
you're broke you're eating tuna out of a
[__] can you know you're ready to
stab a [__] you know i'm saying
like you're like what the [__] that's
why you're beating people up then you
get this happiness in your life so what
is your point of view today
you don't see stipe fighting every 90
days do you no
i think he's gonna fight somebody i
think maybe jon jones or something like
that i'm not even sure but my point is
just like a fighter slows a little down
we as comedians writers
actors
musicians
songwriters
your point of view has to change in a
way
you know if you listen to
one of the greatest [__] albums is
back in black you know commercial
success
uh they lost the singer it's just a
great album all around
what was the album after back and black
for those who suck the [__] we salute
you
no no for those who like to rock we
salute you
but if you listen to the beginning of
that song
okay you like
i like it but i've heard it before
you
and a lot of times a band will [__]
make 14 songs
go right they'll be on a [__] role on
their third album the the first album's
a success
the second down they got smart and cocky
it sucks dick
you know it sucks dick
uh
sheryl crow's second round i can name
15 horrible second hours because
the band has put eight years into
writing the first town it better be
[__] good
you know what i'm saying you not only
have one song to carry the album
you have three songs to carry the album
sweet child of mine welcome to the
jungle and something else that could
carry the album
on a bad any record label will take
three songs from
appetite for destruction
headline the album and could put fluff
around it and you could call it a
[__] hat but with a first year album
with the first album right off the box
mike's been working on music for four
years i've been working on music for
eight years the drummer's been working
on music for 12 years and the bass
player was a part of another [__]
band so he's coming with some [__]
luggage and some tricks so we're gonna
get together we're gonna play some bars
we're gonna do a couple festivals
whatever is needed our first album is
gonna be a smoker
but we shot up the [__] flames too
quick now we got now we got a gun up
against our head and we got to put a
second down amount
that's as popular as the first style map
you got a better chance of [__]
sucking 18 dicks in a row because it's
not going to happen
you just said it yourself you had four
guys that have been out there for eight
years average putting new music together
and now the record company's giving you
ten months
to
put [__] uh thunder what do they call
a lightning in the package again
guess what you're not gonna [__] do
it so the album sucks but
then again i'm wrong
because led zeppelin too
elton john that second album is [__]
great you know there's a lot of bands
that got a great second album joey so
what the [__] are you talking about but
a lot of women don't eat it because the
barbarians dig up that [__] album
you'll want to shoot yourself in the
head let me tell you some yoko ono had a
bad first stop and that second arm holy
[__] it's called [__] it's called
mental asylum that that's just sounds
and noises and people getting thrown
downstairs and [__] like that you know
there's a lot of people who got bad
albums look at the cars
came out with the first one and came out
with a heavy duty album for the second
one so there is a lot of
exceptions do you follow me there's a
lot of [__] exceptions to the game
here
the third album we come back
uh we're still doing heroin it's good
heroin we got it direct from china so
the album is real good but on the tour
for the third album the bass player hit
the guitar playing the head with a
[__] uh with a triangle
and everybody ended up going to rehab so
now they come out of rehab and they try
to write
the original [__] that they wrote for
the
third album
and they can't do it
they can't do it because they're not
high
so the fourth album takes a knock
and then the fifth album is one of the
best things you've ever listened to in
your life
because now they're sober now they got
their rhythm now they've accepted each
other
you know and but again all this goes out
the window when i talk to you about
aerosmith
because aerosmith right aerosmith put
out five devils
and then died you know then put out done
with mirrors you might as well
shoot your head through a [__] mirror
when you listen to that album then they
put out another bad one and then they
had their explosion with walk this way
with run dmc so
it's all different i try to keep it
you know i never wrote a [__]
sensational special i think i had pretty
good albums i love my it's just you or
the priest so now what i'm trying to do
is capture something in that vein
i've prepared as much as i can
uh
so after uncle
vinnie said
i wasn't
blown over
by my performance it's not like i taped
it and listened to that
my goal was to go up there and just get
it over
and push through [__] 15 to 20
minutes without starting to crack a lot
of people don't understand
[__] when you don't get on stage for
a while
three minutes is a [__] eternity guys
i don't even if you know what i'm
talking about you know what i'm talking
about if you don't
you'll never understand you know mike
and i were making comparisons before
about
what you do before you get into a
business and you know what's going on
and how you would act
towards it we were talking about
different things you know how
sometimes i don't understand things and
then after i've lived them now i have a
little compassion
for what that guy was saying something
that
an artist might say a musician eric
clapton you know eric clapton's been
talking some [__] in the news lately
i'm just bringing up eric cause i like
him you know whatever he's getting old
guys
he's getting [__] old everybody takes
what he's got to say to heart
you know um
what's happening you bad [__]
sorry to interrupt
my [__] soliloquy there the joint is
sponsored by better help online therapy
you might not realize it but headaches
teeth grinding and digestive issues can
be indicated as a stress
other stress indicators include sleeping
too little or too much under eating and
overeating
put simply stress shows up in all kinds
of ways in the world that's telling you
to do more this is how you remind her to
take care of yourself do less and maybe
try a little therapy i never believed in
therapy and a couple years ago i bumped
into a wall
and i called the guys that better help
better help is customized online therapy
that office video phone and live chat
sessions with a therapist so you don't
have to if you don't want to see
somebody on camera you don't have to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress the
joint is sponsored by better help and
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
[Music]
listen
i am doing fine ever since i started
talking to dana about nine months ago i
had better help
it took a while but my life changed for
the better i learned how to deal with
stress i learned how to deal with
anxiety anxiety you have coping
mechanisms and worksheets betterhelp.com
will do it all for you
contact betterhelp.com
and the joint family gets 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz
back to the show
you just want to get it over with and
that was my plan for this week now i
have to buckle up and that's where the
bert torch comes in
you know burke called me a couple days
and i was like i don't know if i want to
do these
and then i agree i said yeah i'm
interested let's talk on monday then
there's people calling me asking me to
pick four dates on my guys
i'm not ready for this [__] yet for all
you people who hit me up this week and
we're like are you doing this are you
doing savannah i don't [__] know
i don't [__] know you know it's the
two weekend tour
i'm either doing the first week or the
[__] second week it's four [__]
nights and this is why i'm doing it
number one i'm with family i'm with bert
so i feel a lot [__] comfortable
i think i'm jumping on the bus with them
to smell feet nut sacks and [__] why
not
you know what i'm saying if you're
[__] gonna go to rome why not when in
rome
plus there's no pressure on me
the headliner has all the pressure i'm
just doing a [__] strong 20 i walk
off the stage and i go to the bus to
smoke my reefer go to the hotel nappy
noodle time that's it
it's a no pressure for [__] days not
to mention for years i've been sitting
here talking to you guys about camps
when i was a kid i went to camp
and how
if i took you
and played bald with you
three nights a week
if i took you and did comedy with you
for 90 days and then we sat down and i
evaluated everything
you'd make improvements
you [__] definitely make improvements
three sets a week times four that's 12
times three that's 36 [__] sets
we would see some improvement we would
see uh
better entries into [__] uh whatever
segways we would see
funnier material we would work on our
opening
to go out there and grab them by the
[__] neck just go out there and
[__] grab them so now you have them
in your side how to explore that you
know we would
we would [__] uh
polish all that [__] down
to a [__] p it's it's it's
it's 20 minutes it's four sets i'm not
gonna you know if i go three and one
it'd be a success if i ate a bag of
dicks in mississippi you know it's the
bible belt
i'm going to go head-to-head with them
you know what i'm saying i'm going to go
up there and go
i'm going to bang them out and they're
either going to
push back or they're going to [__]
laugh you know i'm saying so
that's all the things i got to work on
now i know i got to work on these things
and then my plan is it's the summer time
if you think i want to be on [__]
planes all summer you got nothing coming
it's not happening
i got the girls i'm going to uh
the carolinas mike is getting married my
friend's getting married september 3rd
i got [__] going on what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna keep writing
popping up doing different spots no
[__] gigs there's no reason to go out
there and waste your [__] time what i
was saying to you guys earlier when i
was in la i would do working out with
uncle joey
but i always had 20 to 25 minutes and i
was rotating around and branching out do
you understand i'm trying to say to you
so i don't know
we're talking about [__] truck
drivers
so i would have the foundation and then
i would branch out guess what guys
i would love to do a working out with
uncle joey now but i have zero minutes
so it's gonna be a long
45 minutes
do you understand a long 45 minutes so
that's the reason i'm not doing any of
these gigs
maybe by the end of the summer i put
together an open mic
where i could do 15 up front solid and
at least
showcase three dudes four dudes that's
an idea i had
at the stress factory at uncle vinnie's
you know that's an idea it's close
i'd be helping some young guys out
they'd be helping me out by doing the
[__] show
that's an idea you know but again
there's nothing strenuous i know exactly
how i want to do it i got a family i got
the kids in the neighborhood i got
[__] jiu jitsu i'm loving
i love doing my little working out i
love doing the podcast so i want to keep
everything in balance i don't want to
kill myself and i don't want to get
i don't it's not going to get out of
control yet that i'll tell you
i'm not even
in the mood for that they know not to
even call
there's some people that have called and
i've just said listen take this
go home
go home what are you doing you know i
just got [__] 10 minutes if that
if you think i'm gonna start you know if
you guys want you know if you don't
think agents already contacted me
let's book dates in september if you
don't want to do them cancel i don't
want people too [__] intelligent you
know
people just went through two years of
[__] misinformation and getting
bullshitted and getting their miles
taken from them and getting everything
taken from your jobs your [__]
cubicle
i'm not doing that to people you know
let's shoot straight with people let's
establish trust in the [__] community
again let's just establish trust with
the people that we listen to again i
mean
you know i hope i didn't give you guys
any bad information throughout the
[__] the last couple years i just
told you to put your chin down and
[__]
keep moving forward you know don't let
this [__] take you down and
i wish we all [__] stuck to that
[__] plan you know we did we did
we're all here we're alive and kicking
we lost the battle we lost a few in the
battle of enzio but besides that and the
battle of facetiming [__]
but besides that it all [__] worked
out now we're going for a [__]
for an unsolicited [__] try again i
mean people are saying
[Music]
the numbers are coming back philadelphia
brought back the mask
monday philadelphia brought back the
mass guys and i got to be honest here
this is a [__] glorified headache
because my friend got it up in northberg
and he said this one was
this one was a sneeze that's how he knew
he had it he kept sneezing he thought it
was allergies
and then he felt something in his throat
he went home
and he goes it wasn't even the three
days that omni crime was so
i don't know what the [__] to tell you
[__] all i know is that listen
man i'm happy i'm making forward
progress
uh we all have to
this was a rough period for a lot of
people
i don't know what the [__]
went down with me i have a couple
and believe it or not my allergies were
[__] bad this week that coffin i do
that's my allergies and it ends with a
sneeze
and i almost crashed the car at the
light and [__] cause you gotta you gotta
pull over because you keep making these
weird [__] noises
so i even had like i told somebody that
let me tell you
if somebody comes to you today
and tells you they got bad allergies
listen to them because
i had them and for me to [__] get
them i haven't had an allergy since the
[__] this maple syrup [__]
and dogs and stuff like that and every
once in a while i got allergic to dogs
and at the beginning of allergy season i
usually get a little [__] sniffle but
this wednesday i think i was going to
acupuncture i almost crashed the [__]
car on the nine dog i started coughing
and tearing up and when i cough i get
[__] paranoid i'm like oh i got tb or
whatever the [__]
but then when i tear up and [__] like
okay
it's my allergies i'll come home and
take a clarity and that's it but i need
i could tell i need to take one [__]
today
yeah it's it's uh it's crazy when you
have allergies and [__] like that but i
got everything i got allergies i got a
fungi toenail
i got [__] uh
anxiety i got i got a lot of [__]
problems but
i'm excited about this week man this
week we got to prove our [__] point
it's uh 4 20.
and you know
i don't know
what the [__] i'm gonna do yet i have no
idea
i was thinking about going into the city
and seeing rachel over at the stand
um
but a lot of these nobody's at the stand
that night no worry
no big j okay none of those guys and i
feel like a bully
like when you walk into those clubs and
there's a lot of young comics
i always feel like that [__] what's
that old guy doing here
come on man he already did what he had
to do it's our chance to [__] like
i'm one of those guys i'm very [__]
uh
self whatever and like i i feel
embarrassed sometimes
you know i know what it is to be a young
comic i know what it is to be a young
comic and to have it set for 10 minutes
on a wednesday in new york city and for
some guy to come in and for them to say
hey you can only do five minutes
see what i'm saying i don't like doing
that to people
i don't it's like when you
you know jiu jitsu is a very
compassionate sport because i'm not
i'm not punching you in the head and
making you bleed if you're my friend
that i care about humanity all i want to
do is maybe
choke you and put you to sleep maybe
control you maybe just
show you a little pain
with a kimora and go
knock it off you know this is what we
have to do where in another
situation you know i could kick you in
the stomach i would kick you in a
nutsack and blood would come out of your
dick
while i would kick you in the stomach or
i would kick you in the [__] head
which jiu jitsu is very compassionate
you know
when i got into county i was very
compassionate and i very am
compassionate because
it all rose up trust me guys i'm not
gonna say i've had my minutes
i've had my moments you know the
some young comics think they know it all
and they want to get in your face and
you got to tell them hey slow down
i've been doing this for 20 years you've
been doing this for everything but three
[__] minutes
slow the [__] down you know that has
happened and then the comic will come
back to you years later and go hey man
thanks for that night i didn't know and
then most comics do
trust me i'm telling you
but now that i'm older and i'm you know
listen
uh
i was doing comic every other weekend i
was i went from doing clubs to theaters
you guys know i was at the comedy
store i knew a lot of comics and
after the transition two years ago i
don't know a lot of these comics
i look at the
the lineups at the store you know i was
at the store for 23 years
i i don't know those people
you know not not that that doesn't mean
they're bad comics
that just means i'm getting [__] old
when i look at the comics that uh
the comedy seller you know i know rob
bobby kelly and i know
you know jim norton i know a lot of
those guys but i i don't know everybody
these guys came out of nowhere and i'm
sure if they're at the cellar they're
[__] great comics
i'm sure they're at the comedy store
they're great comics but it's their time
now
it's that [__] turn now
if i want to go out i could go on the
road and do weekends and [__] like that
but during the week the workout things i
mean listen there's no rules to say i
can't show up
but i'm just letting you know how i feel
sometimes if i walk in a room with a
dollar's there
and jim norton i don't feel too bad
because i'm not the only bully in the
[__] room you know what i'm saying
but if i walk in these young guys look
at me and they're like ah you know i'm
sure two of the comics are going it's
nice to have you here i watched you last
week at the stretch factory i saw you
last year in dc
you know it's kind of nice but then
again on the other hand and maybe
they're not thinking or saying this at
all that's the paranoid that's the
paranoid paranoid mind of a comic maybe
they're not thinking this at all maybe
i'm just [__] worrying about nothing
for no reason
maybe they'll like that i'm there maybe
they'll all hate that i'm there i don't
[__] know you inspired a lot of the
[__] to get up there too
i don't i don't know i don't
i don't feel like this you know i don't
feel like that
it's not even to do it humble like you
don't even
i don't feel like that sometimes because
it's like what the [__] i just don't
want to crash on that parade you know
you know how many times people tell like
eight people from their work
like you know how many times
you have a day job you're just
transitioning to
louis ck
brought you into connecticut for a gig
with him
you're just getting into stand-up you're
thinking about quitting your day job
and all of a sudden you're like you know
what i am going to quit my day job i'm
going to book a night at the stand
and i'm going to invite my employees
and after i kill
i'm going to tell them that's a dog
i've been in a lot of fun i've done a
lot of comedy shows mike
and you'd be surprised
and you go you know after i kill i'm
gonna tell the audience that i'm
quitting my day job and i'm gonna
do comedy professionally
don't i did it you know
you do [__] [__] like that that's you
know
and uh
what if i'm the guy that [__] goes up
before him
and destroys his night i don't know him
and that was his plan to go up there
kill for eight minutes
and then quit comedy you know what i'm
saying i mean listen
the chances of this happening guys are
slim and none
but it [__] happens and then you got
to feel like a [__] [__] afterward
when the guy's crying and shy like that
because he he's not even cut out to be
like a comic
he's like one of those guys that's going
to do comedy for two years
and then he's going to join an improv
troupe
and somebody's going to sneeze on him
assam he's going to go [__] this i'm
going back to the office
so it's like
i'm one of those guys that i respect the
youth
i wish i could put together a night
where
but then again i couldn't like what tony
does would kill tony
but give them constructive criticism
like do constructive criticism but then
again
you can't judge a comic listen i'm gonna
tell you guys a lot of things i can't
judge you in three minutes mitzi sure
could i couldn't you know i couldn't god
bless her um if you sent like there's a
kid that's been hawking me on twitter if
you send me material i can't i can't
judge it
i gotta see you
in front of
30 people
and i could be a judge now there's a
problem with that
do you think i'd come up to you and tell
you this joke sucked you know how many
shitty jokes i have
so do you understand me i'm not one of
those guys like i like to i could do
something for you in a positive
but then i wouldn't really be helping
you
you know what i'm saying if everything
was roses
i wouldn't be helping you i'm not what
i'm [__] saying is i'm not the guy to
tell you that you suck
you need help um
why don't you get my
environmental writing package
and i could go out to like you know i'm
not that guy i'm not that [__] guy
that's going to tell you that
you know either you got like whenever i
go up to somebody it's because that
[__] killing when i went up to
eric rocha when i went up to the
agastino when i went up to
you know [__] uh
matt fultron who
when i went up to rachel when i went up
to all these peoples because i saw
something i didn't go up to them and go
hey
you [__] show suck
what's that
yeah the show i can't i can't do that to
somebody you know when all that all
those people were saying all that [__]
to me those women there was one woman
that
i went up to the store a couple times
and this girl was really pretty
really quiet and really sweet
okay and guys i got a daughter you know
you know i ask sometimes
i say some crazy [__] we were in the
green room
and just you know like i kept doing the
show i think it was sarah mello's show
i miss sarah mellow she books a good
show
uh
and she's really cute and the girls that
would come were like they're [__]
cute she had one friend that we talk
about weight watchers all the time a
little chunky cute girl but there was a
girl that she always put up that she was
helping out i'm sure the girl told her
i'm just want to come up here for free
you know girl was [__] beautiful
but it wasn't kim kardashian beautiful
like hot to try
it was like natural beautiful something
that's really rough to see she was
really really naturally beautiful
and i saw up there like three times and
she would call me uncle joey and [__] i
got a kick out of it
and when i get there and i [__] sit
on the couch and i look up at her
and she had a great body you know she
just had a great body just comes with it
when you're that age you know
and i couldn't take it no more because
when i was coming in one of the weeks
i watched it for a little while i'm like
this [__] girl's funny
you know but i only had one problem when
i had a problem that her tits were
[__] ginormous
and they stuck out like two machine guns
yeah so we i was in the green room and
she's like hey uncle joey how are you
doing i'm like hey can i talk to you not
right away i didn't just go in there and
go tonight
she said something to me we were talking
back and forth and i go hey man can i
talk to you for a second outside i go
listen
i go i was watching last week and you're
pretty [__] funny
you know you really are funny i mean
yeah you're not ready to call caa and
tell them to book your radio city but
you're [__] funny you're on your way
you know you know when people on their
way you're like okay if this guy's doing
this now and he's and i've seen him up
here like eight times he's on his way
so i said to i go
you're saying some great [__]
but
those weapons you have there they're
weapons of mass destruction yeah
they're weapons of mass destruction that
aren't needed
and you're killing other than that so
if you're killing on the natch why would
you put those there that clunky girls
are not gonna like it
and she was like you know what man i
really appreciate that
and that night i saw later on and she
goes i worked i went up there and i
covered them how did you know 30 [__]
you know you just go to shows and you
start doing you don't even have to say
nothing to the girl i just watch her and
then i watch the girl with little tits
that hides them and i'll see who did
better you know and after you see who
did better you're like oh those things
just get in the [__] way you know so
she came up to me she's like that's what
i could do for you
i could twist you do little things like
like when matt barry said to me hey you
need to [__] wear a nice shirt you're
going up on stage with a [__] t-shirt
what nobody had you didn't have time to
hide his shirt what happened you know
there's all those little things you know
how to grab i could tell the
i could tell
i'm trying to say the greenness or the
immaturity and they're both i can tell
when somebody's not experienced by why
they're holding the mic
so if you came to if you came to my club
and i was showcasing you not that i have
a club and not that i would ever
showcase anybody but if i was showcasing
you
even if you had good material
i shouldn't say this to you but it's
true the way you hold your elbow up
pinky elbow i could tell how
inexperienced you are and i couldn't
hire you for the big big rooms for a
little room as i could because it
doesn't matter
but just the way these people that carry
their elbow out it's got to be tucked
into your rib
and it's little things like that that
you know
if i ever had the time to figure it all
out i would like to write a book it
would take me like 10 years if you think
this one took me [__] and the release
date on my book is
may 20th the 23.
the date just
the date just got released on thursday
it went into the book convention or
something like that so
guys i can't push it up i can't speed it
up
obviously i'm not the rock
or mark wahlberg or any of those
[__] that could call up the
publisher
and say i want my book out tomorrow i
don't have that type of juice
so i guess we'll all wait until may 20th
until then i'll tell you a story a month
just to keep you [__] alive how's
that [__] tuckers i'm thinking of doing
an ari storytelling show may
at the comedy underground over in uh the
village
just getting my story shops going up too
so there you have it [__] you
see you think i was gonna show up on a
monday
with no explanations
but uncle joey showed up on a beautiful
[__] monday
the 18th ready to rock this is a big
week big week and more reasons than one
but uh
the guys from laughing gas are coming
out they're gonna bring us some [__]
uh
the new
rainbow ruts
and there's another brand they're
bringing out that's
up to date so we'll be excited there
and uh that's it [__]
and 421 is legal in jersey
plus cops could eat edibles in jersey
so i'm gonna be dosing a bunch of
[__] so if you see a cop
swerving with his one light on
uncle joey dropped the 200 abx on that
[__]
uh that's it and that's that i love you
[__] it's monday we got a
fun-filled week going
and i don't know what else to [__]
tell you i'm feeling good i'm looking
good
we're in a great position and uh
like jimmy smith says in sunday anarchy
you guys wanted me back
i'm back hey vatos
i love you [__] with all my
heart
do not forget i'm gonna take care of you
[__] if you go
to the ice cream shop
on 420 i'm going to tell you what i'm
going to do for you real quick
because i love you [__] with
all my heart i don't want you to think
that you know
[__] joey moves to jersey
he forgets about all of us
it's never gonna be that way
so what i'm gonna do is this for you
[__]
uh if
you come in to
uh
the [__] ice cream shop
if you buy
an eighth if you buy
laughing gas at the shop will be buy two
get one free
plus
the shop will also be giving 25 off
everything that day so if you like the
abx capsules 100 milligrams 50
milligrams 25 sleepy time the kikamoti
is going to be on [__] sale
you know all that [__] you guys like
plus
uh rainbow ruts white truffle
sashimi
buy [__]
two get one free how's that for you
[__] after 25 off so we're
gonna take care of you i'm not sure what
the other shops are gonna be offering
that have uh laughing gas they might
have discounts also
if i hear anything i will
tweet you [__] or instagram you
[__]
but besides that
it's all over but they're shouting i
love you [__] with all my heart
i express i appreciate the [__]
support
and now for a [__] word from
sponsor jack
all right i want to thank you bad
[__] for everything you do for
me for your support the love
but the joint is brought to you by it's
420 week how we're not gonna [__] be
sponsored by the best [__] bong pipe
bubbler in the market
the freeze pipe get an ice cold hit
every [__] time it's like i freeze
my [__] nut sack and you lick it and
your tongue gets stuck to the skin just
joking here's how it works
the pipe comes with a detachable chamber
you freeze beforehand when you're ready
to rip the hot smoke passes through the
frozen pipe
cooling down the smoke as it goes into
your [__] lungs voila you'll be so
[__] cold you think you're frosty the
[__] snowman listen it's tremendous
it's like living in colorado all over
again you open up your door you get the
snow you put in your bung
but now you can do it with freeze pipe
from the courtesy of your own [__]
living room it's non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
frozen longer freeze pipe cools down the
smoke by hundreds of degrees so do me a
favor joint listeners go to
freezepipe.com
pressing code joey j-o-e-y
and get 10 off your first thought i'm
going to save you some money today
whether it's the bung the pipe
the bubbler we're going deep into the
murky waters on 4 420 with the
freezepipe.com
pressing code joey j-o-e-y to save 10
percent if you could smoke from it
freeze pipe makes it
the joint is also brought to you by
better help listen to me
everybody has problems from time to time
whether it's headaches teeth branding
anxiety
listen
better help or put you back together tip
top magoo listen stress shows up in a
lot of ways anxiety shows up in a lot of
ways
and in that you know in a way that's the
world telling you
to do more but this is your reminder to
take care of yourself do less and maybe
try a little therapy talk to some people
let them know what's on your mind what's
on the hangnail let them know how you
feel ever since i've been with
betterhelp you guys have seen it i'm not
stuttering anymore
i got more confidence in other words
uncle joey's back because it's
customized online therapy that offers
your video phone or even live chat
sessions with a therapist
if you don't want to see nobody i get it
you don't have to see nobody that's what
better help does it's much more
affordable than in person therapy give
it a try if see if online therapy can
help lower your stress the joint is
sponsored by better health and listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz the joint is also brought to you by
zip recruiter
listen whether you're hiring whether
you're looking for a job the zip
recruiter is going to take care zip
recruiter uses powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
up
with the job you're offering or the job
you're looking for let me tell you
something i made a mistake and put some
information stuff on a zip recruit i get
i get things for jobs every day and i
don't even have a resume that's how
strong zip recruiter is
they review the candidates and invite
your choices to apply for the job that's
why zip recruit is number one rated
hiring site
in the us based on the g2 ratings and
now you can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey
zip recruiter a better way to hire i
want to thank better help
zip recruiter and the freeze pipe but
most importantly i want to thank you
savages for all the support i'll see you
[__] wednesday morning
tip top and johnny magoo i love you stay
black
you